Ubuntu comes with a firewall
pre-installed called ufw, but
it's not currently active.
You can verify this by typing command,
sudo ufw status.
Status: inactive.
Let's start adding some
rules to our firewall,
then we'll actually turn it on.
If we think back to the wall
of boxes from our last video,
we were initially blocking
all incoming requests.
This is a good practice, as it makes
it much easier to manage your rules.
Just block everything coming in,
then only allow what you need.
We'll establish this default,
deny incoming, by using this rule.
We can also establish a default rule for
our outgoing connections,
any request our server is trying
to send out to the internet.
We'll set this rule by using this
command, sudo ufw the default rule,
allow all outgoing.
Go ahead and check the status of your
firewall by typing, sudo ufw status.
You'll see that it's currently still
inactive, which is a good thing.
We're just configuring our firewall now.
We actually have to turn it on ourselves
once we have everything how we want.
If we were to turn the firewall on now,
we'd we blocking all incoming
connections including SSH, which means
our server would be dead in the water
and completely inaccessible to us.
It's now time for us to start
configuring the firewall to support
the various ports and
the applications we know we'll need.